so what what was the first thing you did
after you got off to uh Hawaii since uh
me and Joey just went off and rested and
uh what did you do Connor
what did I do you went to go see a
certain movie oh you went in Hawaii yeah
so I so John Wick four doesn't release
in Japan until September all right which
is like what the [__] why is it just how
long does it take to make subtitles yeah
like that's that's like six months
translate as a crying right yeah some of
the scenes are in Japanese like what
what I don't understand why it's taking
so long to get John Wick 4 out and so
like I'm a massive fan of the John work
series I've watched like every single
one in the cinema when it came out I
[__] loved it they're great and like
I I think they're like the best action
uh I guess what would it be called it's
not a sequel or Trilogy it's a
quadrilogy yeah series it's the best
action movie series I think we've had in
like
for such a long time like and even some
of the greats of action movies like I
think this holds up if not is better
than a lot of my favorite action movies
damn yeah and so I was you know and John
mc4 looked insane they had such an
insane cast of goats uh and so I was
super pumped for it and I realized okay
well it's the week after John Wick comes
out in America we're in Hawaii and
there's got to be a theater in Hawaii
sure enough there was one right next to
the hotel uh so the moment I found out
that we were like the time we were
arriving like 12 I booked the cinema for
2 2 p.m I was like I'm going straight to
John Wick when I land so we got in I
said I booked three seats to John Wick
right you picked three he puts three
seats because I was like if somebody
last minute wants to join they can join
if not I get the extra two next to me
because he was like packed yeah of
course because everyone wants to watch
John Wick yeah because it's John [__]
Wick you want to watch it so
I had like they were like recliner
chairs too dude theaters theaters in
America are so [__] they are the food
is the food is insane in the city I got
a chili dog and I was fearing for the
worst that it was going to be like the
spray chili it was like actual cheese oh
it's not chili and a great hot dog and
the popcorn was great it was massive I
was so happy and so know all your
favorite things nobody came with me
no I wanted to watch John McFall can you
believe that well to be fair I haven't
seen a single job also yeah I haven't
seen the third one yeah I will I will
come on come on and so I just
immediately went there and I was so
happy and it was it was rammed so I was
kind of happy to have the two seats next
to me it'd be free
um and then one guy tried to sit next to
her he's like I was just my seat I was
like it's certainly not your seat I'm
like boom boom boom it's my shoes buddy
I would say like you could sit next to
me I'm just saying like no no it's
actually not your seat actually I booked
up all these seats for myself which is
great because I had like I felt like
[__] and also I'd ordered way too much
food yeah so I had to like I was like
putting my [__] on the other places and
like I could because they gave me this
giant ass tray for all this food and I
don't know how I would have managed to
eat anything if I had just the my lap
because I would have been like so I just
put things away and it's great I loved
it I guarantee everyone else in that
Cinema was like look at this fat [__]
yeah because we hadn't eaten so I went
to town like this is like a lunch
breakfast I always do that I was living
my best life it was three hours long too
holy [__] [__] it was so good it was so
good and like so was it the same length
as Avatar uh yeah no I was a little
longer I think actually okay three and a
half hours all right it was three
something either way John Wick was I
like normally when you come off a plane
you might be a little sleepy but there
was no sleep at all this movie was so
[__] good this is insane it was such
a good film best one out of the four
what's your what's your favorite one
yeah what's what's your John Wick's here
yeah it might be my favorite one I mean
it's got Donnie Yen
he's so [__] good in it yeah like
obviously we've talked about how much we
like martial arts films yeah is the goat
I never realized because I don't think
I'd ever watched a Donnie and film where
he speaks a ton of English his English
is cracked and I think because his I
think is in one of the videos I watched
his mom uh opened up her uh martial arts
thing in Boston it was crazy how well
all these new characters just fit right
in it really felt like the one that
um I guess because he just focused on
ending it didn't like some of the law
that they kind of built in some of the
other John Wick movies we kind of felt a
little bit convoluted yeah and this one
it was just action like I think he says
a total of like 300 or is it a 300 180
words like he says barely any words in
it right yeah and the action scenes are
so goddamn good so wait is this the last
film is it the last drama right uh at
least in terms of yeah
um before John was like yeah it is this
is like an end of Ava kind of deal
whereas no no it's the last one
it's so [__] good and I was like it
made my week it made it made going away
worth it I would have gone a lot I think
I would have gone to Hawaii and if I'd
gone on that if I'd have flew do I
watched John Wick got on the flight back
that evening I'd have been happy yeah
I'd have felt like it was worth it it
was genuinely amazing like it was such a
good film all right holy [__] watch John
Wick 4 if you haven't already yeah
honestly like you'd think going to
Hawaii for the first time he kind of
would not stop talking about like some
of the stuff he experiencing in Hawaii
but in Hawaii he just kept talking about
his highlight Being John Wick dude it
was so good like actually the one of the
best films I've watched and so I'm so
[__] happy it turned out good so good
Donnie ends The Goat in it as well he's
so good yeah would you like do how do
you feel like John Wick Stacks up
against the classic like action movies
because I feel like you know you had
like the classic 80s action movies and
then that kind of like the rambos yeah
like the rambos and like the
Schwarzenegger kind of era and I feel
like action movies are kind of
[Music]
you know fast the whole Fast and Furious
franchise uh like the John Wick
franchise now as well to be a little bit
of a SIM for a moment like I mean Cano
obviously works very hard and has his
entire career on like martial arts yeah
so like even though he's a great actor
he's also a great stunt man and martial
arts person I guess to the practicer and
like it's like the the accumulation of
all his career of practicing different
elements of uh stunts and martial arts
just coming together it's like I don't
think of an I can't think of another
like actor who is more like a
traditional actor who has invested so
much into this kind of space who could
pull this off like this because like you
watch I watch action movies after
watching John work and I'm like holy
[__] the amount of cuts and shaking of
the camera is insane it's like you watch
John Wick you're like oh that was a 30
second uninterrupted camera angle of him
just doing an amazing choreographed
fight and it's like holy it's like the
old school like Jackie Chan film yeah
it's so good it's so impressive and like
the the mixing of the the style like
martial arts with like guns is so cool
and it's just like I personally I think
this is probably like it's John Wick 4
kind of sealed it for me where this is
like probably my favorite action series
of all time right I think genuinely for
me uh maybe not like martial arts but
like for just yeah I think it's my
favorite of all time yeah I genuinely
think so it's so fun the whole world is
Fun the whole assassin world is very fun
and engaging and like God it's just so
good maybe it's recently biased but [__]
is it fun I don't I don't know why that
you know every time Keanu Reeves stars
in the film I don't know why I love the
fact that Keanu Reeves just plays Keanu
Reeves he's so dedicated to everything
and just the the craft of amazing one of
the most wholesome persons yeah right on
the face of this Earth yeah right I
think it's just because he's you could
again I think there's that feeling where
like you when you watch someone who just
loves what they do yeah and is dedicated
to the craft and and it's a nice person
on top yeah that's a great person like I
think it's just hard not to just like I
think even if you don't like action or
don't care for the John Wick series I
think you can't deny that watching him
perform on the scream is just like a
delight yeah you know and dude some of
the stunts that he does is like holy
he's 50 and there's some of these stunts
he's doing is insane I just I the whole
word of the series is just insane it's
please watch it if you haven't I know
it's not for everyone but it is such a
delight to watch the thing is though
after see off you know after I've seen
John Wick one and two at least it's just
ruined any other role that he's played
because all I see is John Wick now you
know I I watched like the new Matrix I'm
like this is just John Wick in The
Matrix you know I played cyberpunk 2077
I'm like it's John Wick and cyberpunk
because he's just like he just plays
in the best and worst way it's just like
I only see like Keanu Reeves or the John
Wick area
which is which is great which I I
[__] love it's the bad man it's I
think it is the beard his look is Iconic
yeah it's it's iconic look
just do two martial arts and a suit is
just a [__] nice to watch I don't
know why it's so good it's anything in
the zoo
please watch John Mike he was like this
old [__] week yeah I was like I was
like I talked like this just to nobody I
think they were eating dinner I was like
guys John wait for please watch it kind
of would have random conversations with
people in like the lift uh just talking
about John Wick four that's how
dedicated
how's your day going my day's going
great I just saw John Wick I'm like the
precursor to like what the Rick and
Morty fans became for John Wick like I'm
like have you seen Rick and Morty you
have to watch Rick and Morty oh my God
I'll get bored of it in a week but my
when it comes down to Japan again I'm
gonna go watch it I might have caught up
with the uh
because then I'll be six months and I'll
be like God I want to watch it again I
know I do such Delight dude so [__]
good yeah I mean there's kind of like a
lot a lot of films coming out that
interest me which is rare you know we
have like the Super Mario Brothers film
coming yeah I think I think we've kind
of now seeing kind of like the the you
know when roughly now is I think when
films kind of stop being affected by the
pandemic as much yeah so I think we're
kind of getting more films well it's the
past two years have been a drought it's
just it's just nice because the past few
years and it doesn't it doesn't even
feel like the past two years it feels
like the past like four or five years
has just been hey Marvel movies which is
great I enjoyed endgame you know I enjoy
I'm I'm still as much of a Marvel fan
even as you can be as even though like
phase four as brothers no one likes this
face as a soccer ass
um and I was hoping Ant-Man would be
better it wasn't it was did you watch it
I I was going to watch it and then I saw
reviews and I'm like okay this is a
plain movie easily swayed by reviews eh
hey I mean I I kind of am because
especially when it comes to like theater
going to the cinema I I want to make
sure I'm not wasting my time yeah I'm
that guy it's either Cinema or I watch
at home or if it's a Marvel movie that's
mid I'll probably watch it on a plane
you know which is what I've what I have
been doing with like the rest of the
movies this entire yeah
um so it just seems like there's not
been deciding now yeah there's not been
there for a long time there just wasn't
a lot of choice of films that I wanted
to see if it wasn't like a Marvel movie
but now there's like so many films are
like [__] is that new uh that film I
want to watch I think it's coming out
this series The Open Oppenheimer movie I
really want to watch it yeah oh my God
what's his name oh my God uh [__] I I
was literally about to say it
Christopher Nolan that's it it's
Christopher Nolan and oppenheim is
played by
dude oh my God what's the guy's name
Kyle look it up
he's the guy in sunshine
oh the actor Killian Murphy Killian
Murphy yeah he plays like Oppenheimer
the the guy who made the atomic yeah
[__] awesome yeah I'm really high I'm
gonna have a good year of Cinema
hopefully yeah I'm really really hopeful
I don't know Christopher I've realized
exciting movies you know she does he
makes I what I love about Christopher
Nolan is that even if his movies you
know sometimes are a bit experimental at
least they like break the mold I don't
feel like I've like when I watched it
when I watch the Christopher Nolan movie
I always come in with a new experience
right
um even if a lot of his movies have had
because some of his movies have had
issues with it I I look back to all of
his movies and I'm looking back at
tenant now I'm like damn that was
actually a really good you [__]
experience one thing you can't say about
his movies that are boring yeah like
they're always interesting even if
they're hard to follow they're always
[__] Delight to watch yeah every
every now and again I go back to watch
clips of Lieutenant like on YouTube
because I just want to like relive just
how [__] insane some of the visuals
in that world yeah and of course tenant
had problems with this writing I mean
the character was literally called the
protagonist but like yes like which
which is how like it's you know a lot of
the reviews of that movie were pretty
like mediocre you know it's not his best
work but when you look back on an
experience five like two three five
years in the future you're not gonna
remember any of that stuff you're gonna
remember the [__] that actually like did
something new yeah you know which stands
out on like the broader scope of like
Cinemas that came out yeah yeah for sure
yeah like I look back at Interstellar as
well I've been I've been I watched that
again I actually rewatched that as well
because wait why I don't know that's a
[__] good move something about it was
just stuck in my mind
it's it's a really really well here's
the thing again when it came out when I
first watched it I came out of it after
watching what's the Dream movie again
um Inception yeah Inception was what
like sold me on Christopher Nolan that
was that's what made me a Nolan Fanboy
watching that in cinemas in Japan
actually for the first time [__] blew
my mind and I'm like this is incredible
I went into Interstellar wanting
something similar to Inception I was
like this is totally different what is
this I don't understand and the reviews
at that time were again this is still
good not his best work but still good
but it's just something about his work
just sticks with you yeah like makes you
remember it and I think I appreciate
instilling more now than I did when I
first I think I watched I think I like I
never because I think before that time I
wasn't really going to the cinema much
yeah um but I think for some reason in
my head I since I watched at Astra I was
like I don't want to watch any more
space movies I don't know why I watched
this at Astra thing and it was a really
weird Okay film I remember I went to the
cinema and it was literally just me
it was like a midnight viewing of it and
it was IMAX it was giant theater it was
just me all right and I was like man
this is creepy as [__] it was such a
really sad movie as well I mean you
remember it right yeah yeah so I think I
was done with space but I kind of want
to get back into space stuff have you
watched the Martian I haven't watched
that either again because I I was kind
of done such a bang of films as well
that's kind of like a lot of films I'm
like I want to watch down the theater
but I can't anymore yeah like the
Martian to me is like a modern day
Castaway that's that's also a movie
that's aged incredibly well holy [__]
Matt Damon [__] killed it in that
film man making those potatoes yeah
you're making those potatoes almost like
a game theory a film theory about it
yeah and I was like I've seen the
Martian
he plants the potatoes yeah fine he uses
it I think now we've got all the cool
science YouTubers and everyone you know
bringing a good name to scientists but I
remember back in the day it was just
like he was like he was like the pioneer
of like bringing a cool image to like
someone who's just really nerdy and
someone super into science yeah I
remember watching The Martian I was like
damn maybe I should get into like a
science or something like that damn I
wanna I wanna go I want to grow potatoes
on Mars God damn man yeah yeah what a
banger film I think the reason I go to
the cinema less than what I used to
um is I don't know where I saw this
quote or it was probably like a random
Youtube short or YouTube video or
something like that but uh I did all my
life lessons
I remember what they were talking about
but uh someone in the movie industry
you're talking about how you know in the
modern day there's there's not really as
many mid budget movies anymore you know
it's it's it's always either the super
high budget Blockbusters which is
normally like anything Disney anything
Marvel and that has his own charm but
I'm not always in that kind of mood or
you know always like a very like super
Art House yes like super like indie film
or house kind of films and it kind of
made me realize yeah I think some of my
favorite films are the aren't those big
ass Blockbusters you know the cinema
kind of experience it's kind of like
it's kind of like I grew up with
watching a lot of mid budget kind of uh
mid-budget movies well there's a lot
more there's a lot more you know like
you could make comedy movies before you
can't make Harmony yeah what's up in a
comedy movies man not profitable I
watched like a 50-minute like breakdown
of like why comedy movies are just dead
now I think like DVD sales are a big
thing yeah yeah having DVD sales to make
up the poor performance they would have
to get in cinema and you can also shoot
them a lot cheaper but I you know I
guess the audience to Manfred is not as
high enough comedy is dead yeah you
think about like mid-2000s how many of
the most iconic films from the mid-2000s
are just really just think of like how
many [__] animals
you know people love to clown on Adam
Sandler especially like some of the
later films he did but he did some
really good [__] films yeah and I
really enjoyed that era of just oh it's
an Adam Sandler movie I I should
probably watch this out of like dude
like honestly like it's weird that it's
those like weird kind of as you were
saying like mid to like slightly high
range comedy movies or like movies or
just movies like that in general that
like that just stick with me the whole
time because like in my head like when I
think back to like some of the most fun
movie experiences I had like I don't
know if this is like a hot day Night at
the Museum was a [__] family do you
remember that movie yeah yeah that was a
[__] awesome oh like Bruce Almighty
like yeah exactly right those kinds of
like it's such simple films but there's
something about it that just like after
all those years I can still quote like a
bunch of things from those movies right
where it's like today it's like I've
seen a lot of great films recently but
it's like yeah I couldn't tell you as
you know in detail as much as like say
like you know [__] Water Boy by Adam
Sandler you know I mean it's just a
different like it's a different
landscape now like they just said like
everything has to be a lot of money but
a lot of the time I mean like [__]
superheroes are the isakai of Hollywood
you know it's you you just have like no
choice but superhero movies so so when
something like John Wick 4 does come out
or you know the Super Mario Brothers I'm
like finally something different yeah
well they thought initially that John
work was gonna not perform the greatest
because there was like not really much
marketing behind it it was kind of
confusing initially because you're like
it's just a reaction movie with Keanu
okay I'm having a guess
I think people just were shocked at how
[__] good it turned out like the
budget was Tiny for the first John Wick
and even the newest one was really like
kind of kind of small considering how
famous John Wick is I think it can you
Google the budget but I think it was
like 90 million oh really not a lot that
yeah which like these Marvel movies
sometimes like 400 500 million yeah like
yeah like it's a it's a very different
amount of money yeah yeah exactly yeah
100 million which is like it's a lot of
money don't get me wrong but like when
we hear about what some other films cost
yeah like I think Avatar needed to get a
billion to like break even or something
it was like you know it's just like holy
[__] like it's so impressive what they
can do yeah I don't know it's I just
love it yeah I mean like like you like
you were saying there's a there were a
lot more films in that like 50 50
million kind of like 50 a lot too 50 is
a lot but yeah I mean inflation is all
sort of things yeah yeah but like I mean
like that kind of like budget compared
to the the every superhero every Marvel
movie which is like hundreds of millions
of dollars it's all they're both a lot
of money but one is way more money than
the other kind of movie and I feel like
in that like mid-range you could still
explore interesting ideas without having
to be limited by you know being an indie
film you know because indie films are
[__] fantastic by the way but at the
end of this at the end you know at the
end of the day you are you you use the
resources you have and sometimes they
find clever ways to use like the lower
budget but it's it has its charm but
there's there's just a whole category of
like films that I feel have just been
wiped off the Earth in like the past
decade because a lot of the [__]
budget films we hear about lately are
like cocaine bear and the Winnie the
Pooh horror films yeah so there's just
[__] films it's just [__] stupid
they're just meme films right yeah yeah
they're just films that they're like
it's like uh you can make the film on
less than a million yeah and you'll
probably get more money just of people
being curious because it's such a stupid
concept yeah like I think the Winnie the
Pooh film was like not even like 100 how
much was the Winnie the Pooh horror film
I was really tempted to go walking I
think it was like literally like less
than a million like I think it was like
even less than that I think it was
something stupidly low I mean I wouldn't
be surprised yeah it just says
and everyone knew that that movie was
coming out right and so I don't think
the aim of that movie was to make a good
movie I think it was to make a movie
that would just exist and it could be
called a movie
yeah wait wait wait it's like 10 to 10
extra budget yeah easy got a million
yeah
a 10-day shoot that's just that's just a
YouTube video yeah
so so like I think a lot of Studios now
or like like budget Studios saying like
oh wait if we just do something
outrageous somebody's saying [__]
stupid that people are going to talk
about online yeah even the movie sucks
it's really crazy that the Winnie the
Pooh movie took just as long to film as
our Japan road trip especially oh my God
why are you gonna say it like that
like that that's nutty that's [__] up
yeah I mean you want money
is like what's uh what other Classic
Movies should we remake today it's Moana
it's Moana guys this is a [__] idea I
mean everyone ever
I mean everyone said this but like the
remakes [__] suck yeah there's that
little mermaid remade coming out right
okay
Moana does not need a live action and
the fact that they have Dwayne Johnson
doing it which makes sense obviously
yeah but what is the [__] point now
yeah when it's just like an RTX version
of Moana like what is the point of this
movie you just did a mocap version he
just [__] used the mocap footage of
him release there like what is this [__]
he's gonna be like I'm really excited to
revisit the role and do the exact same
thing I did five years ago yeah the
thing the thing about remakes is that I
feel like with remakes you should
there's there's like a everyone everyone
thought about that everyone knows this
it was just an Unwritten rule that you
should leave it the [__] alone for a
while yeah like like you can't call it a
remake if it's like what [__] five
years ago if I could still watch it on
in-flight entertainment it's too goddamn
element it's too early but boys we all
know the biggest news in the movie world
is that Shrek 5 was just announced was
that actually yeah Shrek five was just
no [__] word making a Shrek five I
watch Puss in Boots oh you did it's
insane really it's so [__] good I
actually I I've never seen a movie that
went so hard I really want to watch it
that's actually like that's no joke it's
not the cinemas right now yeah I heard
insane things about it yeah dude it's
like it's it's like it feels like the
one punch man of the Shrek Universe in
terms of like it just came out of
nowhere and was like what the [__] why
is the animation just insane yeah the
the it's I can't fathom how hard they
went on this film not only is like the
just the animation itself just an
absolute Delight the story is so [__]
good yeah yeah I I mean when I first saw
Puss in Boots to start like trending on
my timeline I'm like people are memeing
right this is this is a meme I don't
even watch Puss in Boots one you don't
need to because this film was just so
[__] good yeah damn
um but yeah I'm excited for into the
spider-verse too as well
thank god hell yeah even though that is
a superhero film I don't I don't care
bro that film was so good dude I'm
please if you if you're skeptical you're
like I don't want to Puss in Boots I
haven't watched [__] boots it doesn't
[__] matter don't [__] listen to
anything you say you're dumb don't watch
Puss in Boots too I don't care how you
watch it watch it right now it's so
[__] good yeah more of the story is I
am more excited about cinema this year
than I have been for a very long time
and I might actually and I'm going to
the cinema more often now yeah dude
please do let's go some beers